[Musique]
pourquoi c'est un petit peu voilà ça va
ça va bien et vous d'abord
bonjour dominique méda bonjour on va
parler du travail votre thème de
recherche depuis de longues années
totalement bouleversé dans cette période
de crise sanitaire depuis le début du
confinement ce monde de travail il est
divisé en trois d'un côté ceux qui
doivent continuer à travailler et qu'ils
prennent des risques au quotidien face
au virus d'un autre côté ceux qui
travaillent de chez eux et puis ceux qui
sont mis à la halle harel ceux qui sont
au chômage
qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit cette vision
de la société du travail aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de reprendre vos trois
catégories sur la troisième catégorie
ses dirigeants qui ont complètement
arrêté de travailler ça va être très
intéressant de d'avoir un retour de sur
ce qu'il pense parce qu'à mon avis ils
vont avoir deux perceptions assez
différente d'une part peut-être une
certaine satisfaction on voit d'ailleurs
des témoignages de gens qui disent enfin
on casse avec ce rythme intense qui
était le nôtre auparavant donc enfin
retrouver les enfants un peu de loisirs
un peu de repos il ya tous ceux qui vont
comprendre comprendre à nouveau combien
de travail est important dans leur vie
et combien travail et structurant et
puis je prends les deux autres
catégories le télétravail c'est super on
peut continuer à échanger à
prolonger nos activités mais il ya plein
d'inconvénients énormément
d'inconvénients le fait qu'on est tout
seul face à face à un écran du coup le
fait qu'on est détaché son collectif de
travail et qu'on peut avoir un employeur
qui va charger à fond la barque et puis
surtout le fait qu'il ya une sorte de
vraiment de perméabilité de brouillage
des frontières entre le travail et le
haut et puis la dernière catégorie alors
alors la dernière catégorie elle est
absolument déterminant c'est tous ceux
qui sont au front en première ligne un
jeu file la métaphore guerrière et donc
évidemment tous les soignants mais aussi
les caissières des livreurs les
personnels nettoyage qui vont quand même
souvent au travail la peur au ventre
parce que ils n'ont pas ou ils n'ont pas
eu pendant longtemps les équipements de
protection nécessaire qu'ils n'osent pas
exercé leur droit de retrait parce que
souvent c'est des personnes qui ont déjà
de faibles revenus et qui ont peur de
perdre leur emploi et qui vivent quelque
sorte la double peine parce qu'on le
voit bien là ça y est on a des données
qui commencent à sortir les personnes
qui sont le plus contaminé est en
réanimation et peut-être qu'ils décèdent
du virus ce sont déjà des personnes les
plus pauvres et qui en plus prennent
tous les risques pour aller au travail
souvent d'ailleurs ces caissières ces
routiers avaient enfilé un gilet jaune
réclamait de larmes la reconnaissance du
pouvoir d'achat et ce sont eux les
essentiels est plus utile et ce qu'on
applaudit tous les soirs à 20h
on va faire de cette reconnaissance la
presse est très c'est très frappant moi
je trouve que vraiment c'est une des
plus grandes leçons de la crise c'est
cette espèce de distorsion énorme entre
la hiérarchie du prestige de la
reconnaissance de la considération et
des salaires d'un côté et de l'utilité
sociale de l'autre parce que comme vous
le disiez à part les médecins les
techniciens les infirmières qui quand
même sont des professions prestigieuse
un énormément de ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui au front sont des gens qui
sont dans des métiers parfois pas très
bien considérée souvent regroupés dans
la catégorie emplois non qualifiés sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte il ya 5
millions d'emplois non qualifiés en
france qui sont sous payés il faut juste
qu'on se souvienne que par exemple une
aide soignante ou une caissière c'est un
un salaire net médian à temps complet
autour de 1300 à 1500 euros
et ces gens travaillent à temps partiel
et ce sont principalement c'est ça aussi
l'autre
l'autre élément très frappant un beau
coup de phare beaucoup de femmes en
première ligne et d'ailleurs ça n'est
pas sans lien s'il y a beaucoup de
femmes dans ces métiers peut payer c'est
parce que d'abord les femmes sont
souvent à temps partiel on les oblige on
les contraint à être à temps partiel et
aussi parce qu'on considère qu elle
s'arme toute éternité faire tout ça hein
soigner faire les toilettes faire
sourire elles savent très bien le faire
c'est naturel donc ça n'a pas besoin
d'être payés est-ce que c'est ces
infirmières donc des fonctionnaires est
ce que ces enseignants est ce que ces
caissières ces livreurs ces routiers
vont être augmentés est ce qu est ce que
c est une forme d'obligation presque
morale aujourd'hui je pense que si vous
interrogez les français aujourd'hui le
dirai oui que c'est absolument
nécessaire je pense qu'ils iraient plus
loin et qu'il dirait qu'il faut aussi
revoir la hiérarchie des salaires et
essayer de travailler c'est cette
distorsion donc j'ai parlé entre gerard
j du prestige et des salaires d'un côté
de l'utilité sociale parce que vous avez
quand même pendant ce temps là des
professions qui ont complètement disparu
dont on peut penser qu'elles sont pas
absolument essentiel mais qui ont des
rémunérations exorbitantes
donc je pense que les français il vous
répondrait mais oui il faut resserrer
cette échelle de salaires évidemment et
il faut plus payer les gens qui exercent
des métiers essentiels qui nous ont
permis de survivre dans cette situation
mais est-ce qu'on va réussir est-ce
qu'on va réussir à faire ça alors qu'on
va nous dire que 1 les caisses de l'état
sont vides attendait regarder des chats
en a perdu d'état pointe pipe et puis
les employeurs pareil ils vont nous dire
mais nous sommes déjà prêts à mettre la
clé sous la porte nous ne pouvons pas je
pense que ça va pas être facile mais
qu'il faudra exercer vraiment qu'il
faudra se mobiliser pour porter cela et
qu'on a des solutions moins on on peut
revaloriser toutes les personnes à à bas
salaires et on peut elle alors
précisément prenons l'exemple de
l'entreprise
là on est dans salaires privé on fait
quoi on augmente les salaires on oblige
les entreprises à le faire où on
augmente le smic alors on peut augmenter
le smic même si les comités d'experts
nous disent depuis des années que le
augmenter le smic c'est très mauvais
pour pour l'emploi et puis il ya aussi
vous savez des négociations obligatoires
sur le sur les sur les salaires on peut
revoir ça c'est des chercheuses qui
propose ça c'est très intéressant revoir
la grille de classification parce que ce
sont là des grilles sur lesquelles on se
fonde pour arrêter les salaires et donc
notamment sur la question des salaires
féminins avec des classifications je
vous disais que les compétences
naturelles ne sont pas reconnus là on
peut vraiment travailler et puis de
l'autre côté avec quoi on pourrait payer
tout ça bat avec la limitation des
rémunérations exorbitantes sait très
bien que les inégalités dans notre pays
sont vraiment insupportable elles le
seront d'autant plus aujourd'hui et dont
on peut mettre de nouvelles tranches de
l'impôt sur le revenu et revenir à
l'impôt sur la fortune je pense que ça
aidera à resserrer les gens taille des
revenus et des patrimoines pour terminer
enfin sur ces indispensables les
caissières par exemple dans certains
supermarchés en france aux états unis
elles sont remplacées par des robots
c'est ces caissières ne seront plus
robotisée bhl dans le monde d'après à
votre avis si vous voulez je j'ai envie
de vous dire que on a vécu depuis
quelques années avec cette idée que le
paradigme du futur c'est l
automatisation que 50 % des emplois
allait disparaître et c'est moi je crois
le contraire parce que l'automatisation
elle est coûteuse en gaza et fait en gaz
à effet de serre pour moi la crise
convient c'est un coup de chance qui
nous prévient que la prochaine crise
climatique sera encore plus différente
encore plus terrifiant et donc je pense
qu'il faut là qu on entre vraiment dans
une forme de reconversion écologique ou
c'est pas du tout l'automatisation qui
va être essentiel mais aussi tu es
justement ses métiers ses métiers qui
nous permettent de satisfaire les
besoins sociaux qui vont devenir
complètement déterminé alors à côté de
cette indispensable par contraste est ce
qu'il ya certains emplois qui se sont un
peu révélés inutiles
ou alors certaines personnes qui dans le
confinement sont divers à quoi je sers
personne ne m'appelle je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'exister socialement
dans mon entreprise dans ce temps si
grave est-ce que ça va susciter des des
reconversions est ce que certains
emplois pourraient disparaître
c'est très difficile pour quelqu'un de
se dire mon métier qui mutile 1 c'est le
sociologue david grébert qui nous parle
des bullshit job et d'ailleurs on voit
bien il y avait des enquêtes ont demandé
aux gens est ce que vous vous avez un
bull si jobs alors il commence à dire
oui peut-être que c'est trop dur trop
difficile de dire mon boulot c'est un
boulot qui sert à rien en revanche je
pense que les jeunes vont se poser
énormément de questions et que la
société dans son ensemble doit se poser
la question de la différence je dirais
entre création de valeur pour la société
et création de valeur pour l'actionnaire
parlons du télétravail est ce que vous
savez d'ailleurs combien il ya eu de
télétravailleurs dans le pays est ce qu
on a les chiffres on parle de 40 % des
actifs qui auraient travaillé à distance
alors moi j'ai aussi se chiffre ainsi un
chiffre dont on a beaucoup parlé au
début quand on a pris les mesures j'en
ai pas vu d'autres depuis donc on va on
va rester sur ce chiffre là oui beaucoup
de gens les travail et donc c'est à la
fois très intéressant qu'elle et
travaille avec des progrès fabuleux
infirme nous nous faisons nous les
professeurs nous faisons court
grâce à des logiciels
c'est vrai que c'est formidable parce
que on peut continuer l'activité en même
temps c'est très inconfortable et pour
nous et pour les étudiants et donc je
suppose pour tous les gens qui font des
réunions en télétravail a priori d'après
les premiers sondages les français
regrettent un peu de bureaux
majoritairement haut oui je pense alors
c'est toute l'ambivalence du télétravail
je pense que un ou deux jours par
semaine c'est très intéressant ça permet
un peu de décompresser ça nous fait
faire des économies de déplacement et
donc c'est très bon pour la pollution ça
permet de se rendre en un peu de
services pour la conciliation vie
familiale et professionnelle dont très
bien et jusqu'à maintenant on sait que
certains employeurs était rétif à donner
à permettre va autoriser leurs salariés
allaient en quête du travail mes images
mais imaginez qu'on va tous être en
télétravail tous les étudiants toute
l'airé toutes les emprises c'est
absolument impossible ce serait
insupportable donc moi j'imagine bien
une généralisation mais sur un nombre de
jours par semaine finalement très
réduits parce qu'on a besoin c'est ça
aussi que nous apprend la crise elle
nous révèle des dimensions un peu
insoupçonnées ou un peu négligé du
travail au sein de l'entreprise on l'a
vu aussi au moment du confinement il ya
eu pas mal de tension entre les salariés
et les employeurs
difficile lien de confiance notamment
puisque certains exercé leur droit de
retrait les syndicats ont même incité au
droit de retrait face à des conditions
de sécurité qui n'était pas forcément
optimales les employeurs eux ont peiné à
convaincre que oui il y avait des
masques et qu'il y avait du gel et qui
pouvaient travailler sur leur lieu de
travail est ce que vous pensez qu après
quand tous ces gens vont se retrouver au
moment du des confirmands la confiance
sera là haut c'est une question très
très intéressante je pense que ça va
vraiment dépendre
de la qualité du dialogue social qui
existait dans l'entreprise dans
l'entreprise
qui en effet ont joué à ce jeu c'est à
dire d'obliger les gens à venir quelles
que soient les conditions allaient
menacée lorsqu'il voulait prendre
leur droit de retrait tout ça je pense
que l'effet des tensions vont être
majeur en revanche dans les entreprises
où il ya eu un bon dialogue social je
pense qu'au contraire ça va être un
élément important dont pour pour la
suite et pour le travail ensemble ou à
la sortie du confinement et dans les
entreprises ou si je peux me permettre
l'expression les premiers de corvée
c'est à dire les premières lignes des
essentiels vont se retrouver avec les
premiers de cordée pour reprendre
l'expression du président de la
république là encore vous craignez
détention au fou que chacun compare ce
qu'il a vécu dans le confinement ceux
qui étaient au front et ceux qui étaient
en arrière-plan mais si vous voulez ça
va dépendre beaucoup du degré je dirais
presque de conscientisation et de
mobilisation des personnes aujourd'hui
une grande partie des personnes sont un
petit peu dans la sidération et
l'acceptation elles attendent
je ne sais pas si elles vont revenir au
travail
avec des ordis révolutionnaire avec les
envies de tout bouleverser les syndicats
se sont on lui a une sorte de retour
d'affection là de la part des salariés
parce que ils ont beaucoup aidé dans un
moment où les salariés se pose
énormément de questions savait pas
justement si de l'égaler exercé leur
droit de retrait etc mais voilà je ne
suis pas sûr s'il ne se passe rien s'il
n'ya pas qu'on sorte d'encadrement par
d'autres organisations que les salariés
en revenant à leur travail vont avoir la
force de tout changer on entend que vous
souhaiter qu'au fond notre rapport au
travail change en quelques mots vers
quel horizon alors je vous dis mon idéal
mon idéal ça serait que nous ayons
suffisamment investi dans la
reconversion écologique de nos sociétés
rapatrié de nombreuses productions créer
de nombreux emplois et pendant profite
pour développer de nouvelles
organisations du travail sans doute plus
fondées sur des métiers utiles plus
démocratique et somme toute peut-être
finalement plus évident
merci beaucoup c'est moi qui vous
remercie
[Musique]